so
[Music]
tonight up here is morgana censored tens
of thousands join an extraordinary four
mile line to pay their final respects to
our late queen why are mps
barging to the front
will the queen's death unite the kingdom
or is king charles a catalyst for
scottish independence we'll debate that
and as some of the american media sneer
across the pond i'll take on one pundit
who says the brits have gone bonkers
this week
live from london this is piers morgan
uncensored well good evening from london
and welcome to piers morgan uncensored
we've seen the absolute best of british
this week
pageantry history ritual remembrance
class respect and yes queuing
we love queuing in britain but the best
at queueing i would say in the entire
world this is what sets us apart from
the rabble
there are those who jostle and smile in
sweaty mobs i've just been in france and
there are those like us brits who
politely stand in line
and wait our turn
hundreds of thousands of people are
doing just that even as i speak to pay
their final respects to our late queen
it's a queueing master class they've
come from far and wide with deck chairs
flowers sleeping bags sandwiches and
camaraderie some are waiting eight hours
to file past the coffin and say a final
personal goodbye to the only monarch
most of us have ever known and what's
been striking about the faces in that
queue is their diversity every color
every race every faith every age every
class queen elizabeth meant something to
all of them
it's a reality check for those who think
of britain as a disunited racist hell
hole packed with bigots and bad
attitudes it's actually still great
about this country and a lot that brings
us together and the royal family is most
definitely one of those things
and so do good queues
but sadly not for the first time
our mps has spectacularly missed the
mood incredibly they've each been handed
a pass so that they and four family and
friends can skip the entire queue and
just move to the front like a vip
express lane at the airport but needless
to say
cleaners caterers and other workers in
parliament have been afforded no such
privilege
there are people in that line who've
literally thrown in from as far as
america and australia just to be there
the mp's behavior is rank entitlement
and frankly a royal slap in the face to
ordinary members of the public
why do mps think they're better than the
rest of us
if you want to pay your respects members
of parliament well get in line with
everybody else
well i'm joined now by political
journalist ava santina talk to the
international editor isabel ogshot and
former first minister of scotland alex
samuel so welcome to all of you
alex simond
there are lots of privileges of being an
mp i don't think skipping
one of the most egalitarian cues in
history where you are all the same
should be one of the privileges afforded
mps
i think any member of parliament who
took advantage of the family and friends
four passes must have taken leave of
those senses
i mean i'm i was in a fortunate position
i'm not a member of parliament bb i was
able to pay my respects in giles
cathedral on monday but an mp would have
to be conscious of the miles long queue
and even if offered the opportunity
would say no no i'll either cue with my
constituents or i'll pay my respects in
another way and it would reflect so well
on them if they had but we saw i think
we've seen theresa may in there today
angela rainer from the labour party
they're all
skipping the cue from what we can make
out so you think it's wrong well i i
think it's wrong but also things it's
it's not good politics i mean you would
have thought that an mp could have done
worse than be in the queue right i think
when i saw you know priests ministers
lots of people in the queue helping
people cueing but also getting the
opportunity to talk i just had a i just
had a message from my old good morning
britain co-host uh susannah reed into
her sixth hour of queuing with the
british people with her mother and a
friend and i thought good honor
i have to come in here this is absolute
pompous twaddle seriously they are
members of parliament the houses of
parliament is their workplace why should
they not take advantage of the fact that
that is why should they not have to
queue up like the rest of the british
public i'll tell you why because we do
because we pay their salary so you would
rather tell anyone we paid their
salaries literally paid their salary
nothing to do with it everything to do
with literally profit why are they why
are they somehow
they wasted their time spending hours
standing around rather than dealing with
constitution
they're not actually dealing with
anything at the moment because
parliament isn't sitting and they've got
their constituents who work in harry's
office they've officially done five days
of official parliamentary work since the
start of the summer these people have
hardly any work you can also say that
the queen i imagine the late queen
wouldn't mind if somebody couldn't
because of pressure work queue for five
hours she honestly would not have minded
there are many ways you can pay respect
if you're able to queue for five hours
if you feel you must do it that's a
great thing to do but you don't you
don't have to do it right and let me ask
you two right especially you who've come
out of the traps flying yeah because i'm
led to believe you yourself have skipped
this cube this is going to be framed
really badly this is going to be framed
but it didn't happen no no i don't mind
if you want to find yourself i didn't go
in because i care particularly about the
monarchy or the queen i went in because
it's my job to cover things i went in to
assess the mood and then come on here
and talk about it and tell you what i
think
i am not even remotely feeling defensive
about this i think you're being
absolutely you didn't cue at all right i
think you are being absolutely
ridiculous i am a journalist it is my
job to bear witness to these things day
in day out people like ava and me are on
shows like this talking about the mood
talking about what's going on how can we
do that from an ivory tower
a very good friend of this show and a
great uh
pundit on here
did he do what you didn't skip the life
no he didn't
he had even more reason he could have
easily skipped him he chose not to be
he's not an earning he's not an mp he's
a politician but let me say i bet he
could have done exactly what you did let
me say he would not have done that
because he and i differ from this why do
you think you're better than the british
public so i think i'm better i think
that i've got a job to do no i'm not
saying come on i don't see why should
the british public be queueing for eight
hours in actually a lot of hearts i've
done that [ __ ] and you and we have a we
have actually a former first lead leader
of minister of scotland agreeing this is
a very bad opportunity for politicians
and you too it is
i've been interviewing on the queue for
hours i've put more than an eight hour
shift over the last few days i've been
down in westminster more than the queen
herself like how can you report on
something properly piers if you don't
take advantage of seeing it now i don't
think you don't have to go there to see
what's going on
what have you seen
what have you seen that wasn't on
television
to see how they look in real life either
should i just read about it online
obviously when a bigger thing neither of
them
any qualms about the fact that there are
people there who are in the 80s and 90s
they don't have to who've been curious
no one has to do anything
you've just explained why you did it
you've just explained why it would have
been a good idea for you to go down
there because then you would know that
anyone in a wheelchair does not have to
do that because i was there i actually
saw how it was not in a wheelchair yeah
but your argument just collapsed
human being you said why should people
have to be fit to be queuing so it's not
true
even though your own partner is i said
that i have got other things to do in
relation to my day job which is being a
journalist which is you don't think
everybody else has other things to do
well they've chosen to be there so it's
my job to be there they've chosen to
prioritize pay respects to the queen
that's not what i would do with my time
everyone's doing the same thing
everyone's there to pay their respects
to the queen you just don't think you
should have to kill this man of the
people appears i'm not buying into it
one of the few times that i've seen you
socially you were at the arsenal match
you were in the diamond club you were
not slumming it with a people you were
not in the cheap seats you were in the
diamond you know that because you sat
next to me let's drop this i didn't
avoid it i didn't avoid any queues from
the diamond club of course she didn't
get parachuted in you get the parachuted
into the nicest bit of this you know
what i've i've been on the case of you
stop buying the internet all right
listen let's move on from that but alex
i want to talk to you about this issue
which i had yesterday again about mps i
think it's ridiculous to have the party
conference season now and they all go
off on recess for another 26 days the
speaker of the house lindsay hall has
just come out and agreed with me and he
says they should cut the time of the
party conferences he doesn't see them
return on tuesday 11th of october rather
than the following week i'd like to see
them completely cancelled what's your
view well i i think this idea of coming
back this in the autumn it was i think
the robin cook introduced it because he
was worried about the long recess this
idea of coming back for a couple of
weeks then go off at the party
conference it was always a bit daft i'm
not saying that having mps in parliament
is the greatest thing on earth anyway i
mean you know i think if they
concentrate a bit more than what they
were saying but we all like party
conferences it's a lot of hot air but a
lot of drinking but wasn't it well yeah
no they're meant to do other things like
make policy and stuff like that but look
i i'm not i would certainly wouldn't say
you should con cancel the party
conference season because uh of the
queen's death and i i think far too much
has been cancelled and i also think the
queen would have said that yeah i mean
last saturday they canceled or the
postponed decent ledger now anybody on
this earth who believes that her majesty
the queen would have wanted to see the
legend of the sport that got me it was a
lot of the problems how could you
possibly not think that thousands of
people
singing land of hope and glory and the
national anthem while waving flags would
not be an appropriate way to pay tribute
to it i might have missed out land of
hope and glory but never mind they they
they they you know the whole point is
you have to judge the person now the day
that she died the day after she died yes
of course the day of the funeral yes of
course but cancellation i mean i don't i
agree with people because they're not
trying to do that was all about the show
must go on yeah i don't think she i
think she would have thought for the
funeral i'm totally in agreement with
that let let's talk about yeah can i
just get this clear are they now saying
they're going to come back on the 11th
of october because just to be clear the
conservative party conference ends on
the 3rd or the 4th of october so there's
no reason for that gap afterwards why
can't they just i just don't think
they don't need to carry on listening to
speeches by people who are trying to
improve their political standing i just
don't get it i've been to these party
conferences many many times they are a
massive huli yeah right and right now
with the worst cost living crisis in
decades the idea of a bunch of
politicians on the lash in seaside
resorts that doesn't fly for me can i
just full disclosure i'm going to go to
work of course you are of course you are
you can have a go and you want
and the irony is you'll actually be
lining up for those parties because they
have to for security reasons won't you
yes i'll be doing this
you should not be on the lash let's get
that i will not be on this house
um
scottish independence a lot of people
think that there was a bit of momentum
uh before you know all this happened and
certainly the boris johnson was in a way
almost fermenting that support
they now feel that uh all these events
in the last two weeks new prime minister
uh a new monarch the death of the queen
has actually unified the united kingdom
in a way that very little has for a very
long time
do you think that the cause of scottish
independence has actually been put back
by what's been going on no i don't and i
think it's i think it's really silly for
people to confuse respect for her
majesty the queen with political issues
like scottish independence i mean if you
go back to an even more pertinent point
the death of princess diana which was a
few days before the scottish referendum
and evolution and lots of people said oh
my goodness this is going to change
everything what actually happened was
people spent a week paying respect
princess donna and then the campaign
started again and people voted exactly
as they were going to vote before
princess dana died so i think people you
know hope for people hope that this
great event is going to somehow benefit
when you see how just don't do the work
all right
get on with the workers when you see how
poor brexit is going right this great
seeding of
of this great country from europe we're
going to stand alone and conquer the
world none of that has happened so far
i'm not saying it won't i'm just saying
nothing has happened so far nothing has
happened to make me think an independent
scotland should be following the same
path why would you not have qualms
having seen what's happened with brexit
well uh perhaps because an independent
scotland would have a much
deeper relationship with the rest of
europe and have been the single market
and have all the things that breakfast
so you do like being part of a big union
you just don't want to be part with the
with the english and the world of a
single market right it's really what was
about
about
prosperity
the the smp i've always found weird is
that they all say that they all say look
we can't wait to get away from the
shackles of this union but they would
they can't wait to get shackled to the
union of your opinion okay but well
let's take two decisions the you've
you've mentioned well obviously scotland
would have voted a different way had a
different attitude to europe that's a
big thing why would you rather be part
of the european union because in the
united kingdom yes because the european
union is not the same as an
incorporating union the european union
is a union of states when in my view not
in certain view of others britain was
still an independent country when it was
a european union member germany is an
independent country denmark how would
the border work this is something that
intrigues me as we've seen what a
shambles it's been well we're going to
rebuild adrian's wall
i think we've got an exact analogy for
the border now in the position of our
land
really well well actually northern
ireland has just recorded its best
economic performance since statistics
began why because it's part of a single
video
in a skillful political way you are
ignoring the question where do you put
the border well you separate yourselves
from the well that's why terrible hordes
of the english right okay there's no
people bothered because that's the the
free travel area
no that was established in the 1920s
even before you and i were born peers
but you know in terms of checking goods
that's what's being done in northern
ireland at the present moment the kids
have checked well no that is a complete
mess no it's not a mess that's the point
you know
politically johnson didn't like it why
don't i like it because it's been
successful economically northern ireland
let me say again as its best relative
performance to the rest of uk since
records right so ava you're nodding so
do you agree do you think scott the uk
should break up i don't think that the
uk should break up but i think it's
farcical that we pulled scotland out of
the eu and we pulled them out of the
single market i think that's absolutely
mad it's it's not it's not a silly point
it's quite an obvious point isn't it
really because we are all part of the
united kingdom because why is it mad to
be that the uk operates as one entity
because because you've got devolved
powers that are being forced into damage
in the uk we are the united kingdom the
last
referendum failed right so so i don't
see why why should scotland have its own
say on for example brexit why should
they because it's it's failing though
there are lots of things that scottish
don't agree with that we've done the
scottish we've already done things
we've done them so dirty really exciting
we promised all those fishermen that
they were going to have you know
trawlers full of fish they were going to
have you know massive success and they
have been obliterated by brexit so it's
totally fair to give them another say
all right
let's take a break let's have a little
eat it little chill pill i'm gonna come
back with more of my pack uh mourner's
still queuing through the night amazing
scenes actually in london uh to we brits
it makes perfect sense all this queuing
across the pond they think we've
completely lost our minds i'll explain
the notion of good old fashioned british
respect for one american pundit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to peterborough nonsense
8017
my very lively pack this evening
quite rebellious actually we might have
to put them back in their box in a
moment i want to talk to you
about uh well this is a great clip
actually because i've been wondering
about these guards who've been guarding
the queen's coffin and obviously putting
it in and out of purses and then
standing guard it's a long time to stand
in often quite warm conditions
and we had this guard who collapsed
yesterday she fainted and face planted
just straight down yeah
we can see that again but it was really
let's just see that again um just so you
can see exactly what happens he said
bang i mean that is a real
and then what was bizarre was they they
put him back up and then he carried on
standing there for a little bit clearly
completely out of it until eventually
they realize it wasn't a good idea um
the show could definitely not go on i
really feel for him it must be difficult
you know to have that happen we've seen
it happen in a few public things before
um
and i just wanted to show that
this turned to a more contentious issue
harry and megan
i don't like to keep talking about these
two but for some reason they always pop
up
i don't really i find them very
irritating but
uh today it's reported they furious
because their children aren't she and
lily about to be denied royal titles
this is because harry is no longer a
working royal and laws uh the mother
megan what do you think of this alex
it's completely rubbish of course i mean
the idea that young archie who i think
is three-year-old
is uh going to the nursery in los
angeles and saying this is awful i can't
go i'm only a prince i'm not his royal
highness
it's ludicrous but don't they having
said that yeah i'm just a wee bit
suspicious you see but you're always on
megan's back and i'll read today well
actually
well i don't really know
both of them
but i read that they are objecting
furiously etc i'm kind of suspicious i'm
not sure that they don't ideally express
in the sun no that they're objecting
although we do know we do know from the
oprah interview that they were furious
in that about this potential issue of
the titles
my view is we have the debate about the
uniform i thought if andrew's going to
be allowed to wear one at one event
harry should be able to wear his however
on the titles you can't have your royal
cake and edit can you isabel i mean if
you leave britain and royal duty then
your kids don't get to be hrh sorry i
think they're extremely lucky that their
children are going to be prince and
princess i was quite surprised to read
that and i don't know whether that's
because you can't take that away is it
impossible to take it away but i think
that they should be
extremely grateful that they've got that
and just hey
i just really don't care i think they've
gone off and they're living quite
happily i don't think they care at all
about this title nonsense
why would they tell them
they're off in california they're having
a really nice time she's looking really
fit might i say she's looking probably
the best she's ever looked that's what
she's trying to do that must
have been wild just how nice she looks i
don't think they care i think that we
you know maybe something to do with
getting world protection and i still
think we should pay for that because
they are really you know open to being
harmed
let's turn from two people who've been
spectacularly classless in the last
couple of years to someone who i think
you've been asked
we'll get you back on track um let's
turn to someone who i think is the
epitome of class who just announced his
retirement from tennis roger federer
greatest of all time alex well i have to
see andy molly obviously of course
but in terms of male players i mean a
good argument for the williams sisters
as female players but as male players
federal yeah i mean i felt i was
fortunate enough to watch him wimbledon
twice and the backhand is just a thing
of beauty but also his whole demeanor i
just love it
i like the way he is we look at someone
like curious screaming and ranting and
shouting and thinking about things
well yeah they're good to watch the bad
boys aren't they like making stuff
there's something about federer which is
the epitome of class i think he's a
really good role model and maybe that's
a bit boring i don't know but you know
they've got this huge charitable
foundation don't they they he doesn't do
any of the theatrics any of the
ridiculous faces any of the attention
seeking he just plays tennis brilliantly
and that's his job it's a very nice uh
tribute to him from rafa nadal he's
great rival wishing him all the very
best in retirement you only thoughts i
know you know nothing about tennis
cracking calves cracking calves that's
all i know about him
alex simon are you going to the funeral
on monday well i haven't received an
invitation if i if i if i get one i'll
go although to be fair i'm i was at the
services in jails and so
and uh you know so i was able to pay my
respects there underlying all this when
we get back to relative normality on
tuesday we're facing this unbelievable
economic crisis kwazii kwatima
chancellor is reported to what one of
the first things that he does to solve
this problem is to remove caps on
bankers bonuses i've got to say when i
read that i was like are you reading the
room do you think that people in this
country right now quasi quality the one
thing they want in the cost of living
armageddon is let's give bankers more
money you know quasi is a rich guy
the previous two chancellors were richer
than him right he's the the poorest
chancellor of the last three because
he's actually you don't think he's bad
politicians that's chase morgan he's
it's a very vulnerable point i mean
because you know he's obviously favoring
his
of a uh look i know him really well that
is not how he thinks this is about well
maybe you shouldn't this is about
setting out why don't you go on the
street isabel you're going to about to
start defending this go out the street
and ask the first hundred people you
meet should bankers get a new uncapped
bonus as part of our way of tackling the
cost of living prices i wouldn't be
setting policy according to some vox pop
on the street in the queue but it's not
it's just it's just having your ear
slightly to the ground isn't it i mean
it's just being a bit aware like that
they they get paid
right now it's 200 percent of their base
pay that's their bonus i really don't
know how that's a bit like you were
there again i don't care but there are
children going to school sorry their
children going to school at the moment
who can't qualify for free school meals
there's things there's
it actually is and the other thing i
mean we've had two things from this
government so far under liz trust one is
that the bankers will have uncapped
bonuses so they're going to get richer
all right so you want you want bankers
to be richer as the people
actually get poorer that's fine those
two things are not secondly energy
companies should have no windfall tax
because why should their profits be
stemmed as people literally can't heat
their homes
i've got really bad news for you this is
just the beginning of what this
government is going to do you watch they
are going to do unless are you saying
that proudly they won't last yeah right
exactly i mean look i'm
an oil economist by a profession who
worked for a bank you should definitely
not to uncap bankers bonuses and you
should definitely have a windfall tax
well well i'll give you the serious
economic reason that one factor not the
only one but one factor behind the crash
of 2009-10
was risk-taking in the financial sector
wasn't that risky no no yes it was which
is
encouraged by
bonuses that's why it was brought in
isabel rich people right now don't need
to get richer they don't that's not the
priority yeah the priority of food banks
and kids who can't afford their school
meals
they're going to make 10 million or 20
minutes and they're not even creation
and a rising tide lifts all boots well
this truck is going to cut all the taxis
apparently good but some of the work is
it well how much i tell you what
hammering people on tax doesn't create
more revenue you do realize that you
know about the laughter you realize that
if they carry on with this attitude i
think they are going to get one of the
mother of all shellackings at the
election i agree i agree but why would
you encourage that because it isn't
about winning the election it's about
doing the right thing isabel not only do
i know what the laffer curve is i met
art laffer and i can tell you the laffer
card does not apply to bankers bonuses
we're talking about income taxes what we
were talking about how do you possibly
cut income tax right now i'm not i'm not
cutting in context right now but what
taxes will she cut i imagine that they
will go down the route of that later on
they will probably cut top rate of tax
because it doesn't actually generate
anything all it does is send out you
know what they should do she keeps
protecting me
pretending to be the new maggie thatcher
she should go and study what maggie
thatcher did when she came to power she
inherited a very bad economy and she put
up some taxation
tax on oil companies and then when she
stabilized the economy then she cut
income tax and other taxes that's what
the great heroine of the conservative
party did
this
the tory party doesn't seem to know her
history anyway thank you to my pack
great to see you all such lively form i
appreciate it well coming up the uk is
in a period of profound national
mourning but across the pond in america
many of them think we've lost the plot
we'll debate that next with this
gentleman who thinks we've all gone mad
and ann coulter who surprisingly is
racing to the brits rescue
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back well in the last few
moments it's been revealed that prince
harry will be allowed to wear military
uniform alongside seven of the queen's
grandchildren for special memorial
service on saturday palace officials
intervened after he'd been banned from
wearing his uniform although his uncle
the disgraced duke of york prince andrew
had been given special dispensation by
his brother the king king charles iii of
course to wear one at one of the events
this is a victory for common sense it's
also exactly of course what we've been
saying on this program what i wrote in
my column for the sun it seemed
completely irrational for me that andrew
who has committed in my opinion far
worse
offenses in terms of diminishing demonic
reputation than prince harry that he
should be allowed to wear his ministry
uniform um we've been joined by uh
middleton
british war hero former star of uh sas
on channel 4 it was way better when you
would do it by the way um i agree
we've got you on to defend our country
against the american
media that we're going to be doing in a
moment what is your view about this
uniform issue with harry because
obviously just to be clear if you are a
veteran and you're not a serving member
of the armed forces you don't
traditionally wear a uniform right it's
only serving members of the military but
the royals obviously have honorary
positions and as such that's why they're
allowed to win ed would quit the marines
but he gets to wear one because he's and
so on
the problem it seemed here was they made
an exception for andrew to where he is
at one of the events and i felt you
couldn't possibly do that and not let
harry do the same well andrew is
controversial you know i don't really
want to get into that debate because we
all know you know
our feelings and thoughts on that but
harry have he served you know he was he
was one of the lads you know he was
heavily connected to the special forces
he actually get presented with my
bearing belt when i got back
yeah so i got badge went to paul and
himself and uh prince where
prince harry and prince william were
there and they presented with barbarian
belt and he was known to be one of the
lads and he's served he's been out to
afghanistan he served so rightly so he
should be allowed to wear his uniform i
have no problems that no matter what you
think about him you know he deserves i
don't think you can take away that one
you cannot begrudge him full respect his
military service he did two tools of
afghanistan and i would never begrudging
that at all um i've got other issues
with him but that's nothing to do with
his military service which is which was
beyond reproach um
stay with me because we've got to get
into this big debate that's raging over
across the pond here of course we've
been in national mourning the cue to see
the body of the lake queen is 4.9 miles
long stretching from westminster hall to
well beyond tower bridge if you join the
line now it'll take eight hours to reach
the front and of course it's out pouring
a patriotic further it's not unexpected
here in britain neither the side of the
royal guards marching beside a coffin
date by the crown jewels perched atop a
velvet cushion this is what we do but
does the pompom pageantry burnish
britain's image as a nation of history
and finesse or as some people across the
pond in america think have we all gone
slightly mad is it just
pomp and pageantry hysteria or political
commentator and columnist michael
lutiano and journalist and author and
coulter join me from america and i'm
obviously got the star
well he was he's a former star but he
wants to meet the star of sas who dares
wins when it was a show worth watching i
do the australian show now so there we
go yes and it's excellent because you're
on it and all right michael luciano
you're a columnist
over in america and you think we've all
lost our minds why
well it's the year 2022
and you all still have a monarchy up
there does not have the kind of
political clout that it used to which
in a way makes it even weirder because
it's they serve the royal family serves
no
real actual function
and yet you just kind of keep them
around
but so
i would say like here in america we've
lost our minds even more because i
understand all of the coverage of the
queen's death and the ascension of
charles i get that from a uk perspective
but we here in the united states for
some reason are also all in on the
coverage of the royal family well i
think i think look i think it's it's
buyer's remorse for getting rid of
george iii isn't it you know you wish
you'd never done that you've had a
series let's be honest you've had people
you've had a lot of presidents some of
whom were great and some of whom were
complete turkeys and each time you go to
turkey you think yeah totally
maybe we should have had
george iii and his bloodline and just
carried on you might have had king piers
button have you played your cards right
yeah no the whole reason we fought the
revolution is so we wouldn't have to
care about any of this stuff and yet
we're still caring about it and the
media is in total overdrive george
washington is rolling over in his grave
in a way i guess his point look i can
understand why some americans don't get
the concept of a monarchy what i find
really objectionable is what some
american academics have been saying so
there's this woman called you anya uh
she's actually an academic at carnegie
mellon she teaches people this woman and
she tweeted this i heard the chief
monarch of a thieving raping genocidal
empire is finally dying may her pain be
excruciating
this woman is an assistant professor
teaching people
another assistant professor in rhode
island tweeted she would dance on the
graves of every member of the royal
family especially hers about the queen
now michael this to me crosses a line
and i would feel the same if anyone in
britain said this about a president who
just died what is wrong with these
people
well you know some people just have had
different experiences with
the queen in the house of windsor more
broadly going back to
uh you know few centuries so i can't
really speak to the experiences that
they have had
and their families and their ancestors
have had with the british monarchy it is
not something i would have tweeted but i
am not going to pass judgment really
you're not going to pass judgment
you're not going to say that you condemn
yeah you don't you think it's you think
it's not worthy of condemnation
that somebody who teaches students in
america even though
she wishes the queen died of the
excruciating pain
why wouldn't you condemn that yeah
it's not something i would have said
it's not great i don't know who that
person is i don't know what kind of
clout they have totally look it's
disgusting let's bring in ann coulter
and i think you like
the pomp and pageantry of all the royals
i mean so many americans i know love it
they've been
as obsessing about all this as we have
what's your view
um well i'm not quite an obsessive but
uh in response to to michael's point i
belong to an organization that
celebrates my many many ancestors
to who fought in the revolution that
ended our connection to the monarchy yet
and still i don't want a monarchy here
very proud of those of those ancestors
of mine
but this is a country that was did live
under the monarchy for 176 years i love
the monarchy not an obsessive
it costs less
for britain to have
the monarchy than our national endowment
of the arts and national endowment of
the humanities and i think you guys get
a lot more out of the monarchy i mean
the things they provide i don't think it
would be fun at all to be within the
royalty and i would recommend um the
wonderful movie roman holiday which is a
great movie but really really makes that
point it's a lot of work they can't just
you know poor kate
can never wear like a cut off jeans
skirt and a crop top
she can't dress up all preppy she has to
look elegant and beautiful at all times
and she does they all do they are so
elegant they are role models but i don't
even think it would be a fun life and
they'd do it
and wow did the tourists like it and i
really enjoyed the um ceremony that was
going on this past weekend um they kept
cutting it away from it on msnbc to talk
about you know the evil history of
colonialism i would also add that the
world was never so good as when the sun
never set on the british and also the
whole point
the whole point about this colonial
issue is bringing out middleton again
the whole point which a lot of americans
who are being severely critical of this
queen don't seem to understand is that
she took us out of this
you know she was the one that helped
preside over bringing it out of the
empire
decolonized a lot of the you know the
colonization
she should be applauded for this
not castigated and blamed for the sins
of the past and that's what's ingrained
in our dna that's what's ingrained in
our blood is where we are today a lot of
people want to go back a couple of
centuries and if that didn't happen a
couple of centuries a day we wouldn't
have the most open and welcoming society
as we have today you know when you see
this queen is our grandmother when you
see my grandmother when you see this
academic you're teaching people
saying that she hopes that the queen's
pain was excruciating it's disgusting
it's absolutely disgusting and how she
how she ever thought that that was
acceptable to say about anybody about
anybody let alone a 96 year old
respectable uh young lady like the queen
um how they get away with it is beyond
me it's a good job she's in america not
in the uk that's all i can say i just
find it it's it's a kind of repellent
behavior she's of classic kind of woke
academic um let me bring back uh michael
here michael is there any part of of
all this which you can look at and
wish you'd had a bit of this in america
no
really
yeah really
because i tell you why i think
what what what we feel here
i i've had this chat with american
friends what we feel is that the
difference between your system and us we
obviously have a democratic system of
electing prime ministers and governments
in the same way that you do with with
presidents it's the same kind of thing
but the point of the monarchy if there
is such a a point and you could simplify
it would be that we have this continuity
above the democratic process these are
unelected people yes it's hereditary but
they all understand what their job is
and their job is to act as kind of
comforter in chief to the country
in in in bad times and they do it when
they do it well incredibly well this
queen brought huge comfort and solace to
this country for 70 years and it's that
part of it i wonder whether even if you
don't agree with the idea of a monarchy
do you not sometimes wish that you had
in america
this kind of non-partisan
non-controversial
family
over the top of the politicians
no i have an innate aversion to
hereditary aristocracy i think
the brits as well as the americans are
hard-nosed enough to be able to do
without such a an aristocracy and
you know frankly i regard the
royal family as i regard the kardashians
here i mean they are famous for being
famous they're very wealthy
they
there are too many of them and i try to
avoid all mentions of them as much as
humanly possible i mean you did just as
a country your your immediate uh prior
president was a tv star
reality tv yes and i did not like that
at all right i did not like that at all
i mean your own democracy
is not exactly full proof is it
no it isn't but you know at least we
didn't elect the kardashians i'm not
sure we did much better with trump but
no i no there's there's listen i mean
the best thing charles could do is to
end the monarchy and he would be hands
down my favorite monarch right well
that's never going to happen and coulter
um
could i say i think the kardashian point
actually makes your point piers um he's
right i mean what that's our royalty
these utterly tacky disgusting people
you have a beautiful monarchy i think
you do make a very good point about
having a nonpartisan head of the country
though i agree with i'm sorry is it
michael or matt michael yeah
okay i agree with michael that i don't
want a monarchy here but you know i
don't want bull fighting here i do want
it in spain it's part of of what britain
is
um and i think the colonies all owe
britain for the wonderful things britain
did to them bringing indoor plumbing and
railroads and educational institutions
and ending hideous practices like
throwing the widow on the funeral pyre
getting the resources out creating
wealthy countries out of just third
world hell holes oh no no no the
reparation should be going back to
britain
you know what i mean maybe we should
come over here and be a defender of
britain as your new full-time job
i would like to could i also say
something i really like about um king
charles that i don't think gets
mentioned enough um
i mean okay global warming blah blah
blah i wish you dropped that there are
enough people cover covering global
warming we don't need him doing it but
one of the things i really really really
strongly support and especially having
just recently been in london again um is
his opposition to crap architecture and
wanting to preserve the beautiful
buildings and restore old buildings
london
is such a beautiful city i think it's
the most beautiful city in the world and
you're going along seeing these these
old gorgeous buildings and there are
some modern buildings that are cool and
nice but most of them are just pieces of
crap that get thrown up and
he gets very little credit for that he
has excellent taste um i wish he would
really hit that hard as king and save
london from ugly architecture i never
thought i'd say these words but britain
salutes you ann coulter thank you very
much indeed for your support let's play
a little bit of the anthem in in tribute
to ankle to there
and just for michael just to annoy him
[Music]
he's loving
he's feeling the stirring of his soul
areas
[Music]
and by the way i would stand as well for
the american national anthem uh because
when i'm in america and and it's played
there because i believe you have a great
system too michael i appreciate you
joining me ann coulter thank you very
much for joining me and you're going to
stay with me we're going to debate
whether
bear skins
the hats that are all of our great
guards are wearing should they be
allowed to do it anymore or should they
be banned
we'll have that debate with someone from
peter the animal right organization who
of course are permanently furious about
absolutely everything so we'll have that
conversation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
three cheers for his majesty the king
hip hip
hip hip
hip hip
welcome back the towering fur hats of
the king's guards are iconic and
historic but there's a catch they're
made with real bear fur animal rights
charity peter wants some band joining me
now is jennifer white spokesperson for
the charity and at middleton all right
jennifer
you and i have locked halls before about
a number of issues um why do you want
these banned
well it's simply inexcusable that the
ministry of defense is continuing to
wage this war on black bears
especially when it takes one bear to
make one cap and a viable faux fur
alternative exists and we know in canada
these bears are mercilessly gunned down
by hunters for fun and then their pelts
are sold
to for auction houses
and a lot of the bears when they are
shot they escape injured and then
they're left to bleed to death slowly or
starve to death is there a good enough
alternative to replace this
there is and i wish i could have brought
it in because we've got one of the
actual ones here right so yes is there
one that looks and feels exactly the
same yes the catfish has been designed
by eco pell which is a luxury faux
furrier it has passed all of the
requirements needed um it's durable it's
waterproof the fur is the
say that when it gets wet they're not
good enough they're not well the mod has
yet to actually meet with peter and
ekopel to discuss this in person we are
ricky gervais support doesn't they yes
on this issue a lot of lovely
milton
i don't like animal cruelty
like animal cruelty absolutely some of
the stats here i mean in
a five-year period the mod bought 891
caps for the queen's guard which peter
had estimated took a thousand bears to
die in the process
is it time have we given charles's you
know views about the environment and
everything else is it time we considered
fake versions of this i'm against animal
cruelty as as any normal person should
be but i'm not against culling and
population control you know whether
that's dear whether that's bears well
you know i don't know how the process
works but if there's a culling process
and the tradition is the bear skin you
know they're on postcards they're
part of our culture they wouldn't look
any different is the point um
well if they wouldn't look any different
then there's an argument there of course
there is you know and there's always a
way forward but um do you mind getting
sick of people trying to change our
tradition no i'm not basically
trying to get rid of them wearing
anything that looked like this i'd
understand it i've got to say my natural
instinct jennifer with you normally is
completely disagree with everything you
say uh i'm slightly torn on this well i
mean because
to me it all comes down to if they can
actually create something which looks
and feels the same
why would you need to kill it well
that's the thing and we have created
something that looks absolutely
indistinguishable and that's what we
need to remember it's the the look of
the caps that are iconic but it's not
what they're made from and it actually
just falls out of favor with modern
britain like 95 percent of british
people wouldn't wear for you know her
mod does say that a faux fair
alternative to bear skin cap is
available to any guard who
conscientiously objects to wearing fur i
don't know how many have actually
objected and do wear the faux fur but i
got to say jennifer i find myself in a
very unusual position well i think you
might have a point
and i've been interested i've been
interested to know what the guards
themselves are
whether they feel passionately it should
be
real or not
or whether someone they're already
wearing the faux one well also just to
quickly interject the bears are also not
culled um you know these are which are
deploying you right yeah these are
licensed hunts which is just when
hunters pay to get tags
we're running out of time i'm going to
go find out the half of what you're
saying is correct but if it is i might
be on your side on this matt middleton
great to see you good to see you really
miss you on the show but you're killing
it ever since great to see you both
that's it from me i'm back on monday at
8pm with an extended two-hour edition of
the show reflecting on clinton's funeral
and i'll be co-anchoring the funeral
full spot
i'm tommy dunn and this is talk tv the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i had no idea what he
did is he went on one of the more moves
is going to launch a nuclear strike on
north korea or open up a shark pit that
i'd then fall into
turned out he pressed it right at the
end of the interview and he walked a
butler with a tray carrying it dark
here's the diet coke
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zora silverman prince
william said walking behind his
grandmother's coffin in yesterday's
procession brought back painful memories
of doing the same for his mother the
prince of wales walked alongside his
brother and king charles to take the
late queen from buckingham palace to
westminster hall to lyon state he spoke
as he met well wishes outside the
sandringham estate earlier with the
princess of wales while the queen the
queue to pay respects to the queen lying
in state is now estimated to be at least
eight and a half hours long thousands of
people have walked through westminster
hall today to pay tribute to the late
monarch and one of the greatest tennis
players of all time roger federer has
announced his retirement in a statement
the 41 year old thanked his fans for
making his dreams come true that's all
for now we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]